All right, it's 11:15. Uh, we're going
to go ahead and get started. Before we
do, everyone say evals. Evals.
I was telling my colleague Rose uh who
who's at at the door that I was a
adjunct professor for a number of years
and um the first uh year that I did it I
thought I was going to have this full
class of 130 people every single week
eager to learn and then as the weeks
went on 130 became 60 became 30 became
10. So, I always tell myself that
whenever I give a talk that only about
four or five people are going to show
up, but I'm going to be really excited
to teach those four or five. Um, today
is a a a real blessing because um you
know, we have we have a a packed house
here today. Everyone's excited to learn
about uh evals and I I am excited to to
teach it. Um here's what we're going to
be talking about today. I'll give you a
little bit of intro about myself and the
company that I work for. um an overview
of of the problem statement. Uh we'll go
into the different stages of when people
are building eval platforms and after
that we'll we'll talk about um at least
in in my opinion where I think eval
platforms are going to go. Um but yeah,
this is this is me. My name is Phil
Hzel. I lead solutions engineering at
Brain. I'll go into what Brain Trust is
in a second. um solution engineering.
That basically means I'm the person and
my team are the people that make sure
that people are getting the most value
out of our platform uh and as as quickly
as possible. So I'm fortunate because uh
throughout all of our customers, I I see
uh what the state-of-the-art is in in
both eval and and agent observability.
Prior to Brain Trust, I spent 12 years
in consulting and systems
implementation. I worked for KPMG for
four years. I worked for a company
called Slalom Consulting for eight years
where uh I led the global data bricks
business unit. And I noticed that as I
was um helping my my clients with those
implementations, they were great. So
they were so good at generating these
generative AI proofs of concepts and
none of them were getting to production.
and I wanted to be um I want to be
helpful in making sure that those PC's
could get to production. So I actually
started using Brain Trust because I knew
it helped out in this space. I started
using it as a user and I like the
platform so much that I applied for a
job and I've been uh been here for about
a year. Uh outside of work, uh I I like
to play chess, but I'm I'm I'm very bad
at it. And I like to spend time with my
wife and and my dachshund. Uh dachshund
is is named Pistol Pete. And he's
pictured. Um he's the person in brown.
He's not the person in black. Person in
black is me. Um has anyone heard of
Brain Trust before? Anyone? Couple
hands. How many people have heard about
Brain Trust for the first time this
week?
really okay great wonderful uh brain
trust for um for just a reminder um I
think of ourselves as an agent quality
platform and there's a lot of things
that can go into quality um the way that
we can get to agent quality two main
pillars through eval
observability which we think of as
really similar problems to solve eval
that's what you're doing with your agent
before it gets to production as you're
experimenting so that you can become
confident in your agent. And then
observability is really similar but
you're already in production. Your agent
is uh in front of real usage from real
users and you want to be confident you
want to remain confident I should say
that your agent is performing the way
that you thought that it it would when
you were building it. Um so that's brain
trust. I was specifically told to not
make this a sales pitch. So that's like
really the last brain trust slide that
that you'll get today. Although of
course I'm very happy to answer
questions about our company this week.
But mainly I wanted to talk more
conceptually about um how people start
to mature and and build build these
platforms spoken from a place where we
have a lot of experience in the space.
Uh first why eval are important. Evals
are important because um this sounds
obvious but LMS have extreme
variability. Uh we love LMS because
they're highly variable. There are so
many different types of problems that
LMS can reason to solve. That's why
we're that why you know we're so
attracted to to them as a technology. Um
agents are also of course agents use LMS
as as the brain of the agent. Agents are
becoming the norm in how customers are
interacting with companies. People
expect an agentic experience now. So if
you combine both of those things
together, you really need to be
confident in how your agent is going to
perform once it is in production.
Without doing so, you're going to incur
or you can potentially incur a great
deal of risk um from both a a brand
perspective, a compliance perspective,
uh and even more of a a cost and and and
maintenance and systems perspective. So,
we want to avoid all of those things
happening and make sure that, you know,
our customers are having a great
experience and that our agents are are
um acting the way that we thought that
they would act.
Um, how many people are like they're
doing eval right now, but it's just on a
Google sheet or or some spreadsheet.
There's probably there's no shame in
that, my friend. Raise that hand high.
That's great. Um, there's I and I I
think I think that's great. Like ju just
making the step is is really important.
It's an acknowledgement of the problem
space. And a lot of folks will, you
know, they they'll they'll come to us
and they'll say, "Well, I don't really
understand brain trust because, you
know, all I need to know is how to loop
through my agent with a couple of
different inputs and be able to display
some, you know, handwritten notes and
scores about that agent. So the things
that I mentioned there, three things,
some way to execute your agent, some UI,
sometimes it's as simple as a
spreadsheet to show those outputs and
scores, and then also a way to to gather
input examples. What what I mean by
input example is the the thing that can
initiate a run of an agent, the thing
that can invoke an agent, whatever
information that's necessary for that.
Um, it would be a really short
presentation if if this is all eval was,
I would I would thank you for your time
and I would walk out the room, but
that's not that's not what you're here
for. There is a whole other part of the
iceberg.
It's way more complicated than that.
There are a lot of things that you end
up having to build when you're really
serious about evals. We're not going to
talk about every single one of these
things today. Um, but we will touch on
uh on many of them. Uh, and of course,
if there's anything here that I don't
cover that you're interested in, I'll
leave some uh some times uh time for
questions for that. Also see like a lot
of phones up, so I'm gonna I'll pause
for iceberg pictures.
Um, a couple a couple things while
that's happening. Uh, why is this a
complicated problem? We already talked a
little bit about how the underlying
technology is quite complex. Looms are
are are not a superficial um engine. Uh
but it's also a multi-persona problem uh
bu building these agents. It's not just
something that engineers do in
isolation. It's something where
engineers uh whether whether they're
product engineers or AI engineers or
both systems engineers to get the thing
running. Um
uhmemes that have the domain knowledge.
All of these people need to be involved.
Uh and then lastly it uh eval themselves
become a systems problem. That'll be the
last thing that we that we touch on
today. So, what are the different stages
of of building an eval platform? Um, my
my my friend over over there that raised
his hand proudly um about starting out
in a spreadsheet. This is this is a
great place to start. The the most
important thing is that you just get
started. So, you've got a spreadsheet
and you've got a for loop. You've got a
bunch of input examples that you can
iterate through and you have a way to
execute your agent. So you can say you
can see every time you tweak your agent
how the outputs are different over time.
Um while this is a great place to start
because there is no barrier to entry
here. Everyone has some way to access
some type of of spreadsheet technology.
Um the the returns can be diminishing
for a couple of reasons. Um this is more
I would call this documenting. It it's
not really experimenting.
So while you have this spreadsheet of
you know a bunch of input examples maybe
you keep track across each time you are
tweaking your agent the the different
output that that emitted um that can
become cumbersome to to manage over
time. Of course um it's really
challenging to be able to compare
directly experiments over time. you're
probably not doing a lot of analytics
across those experiments and the
analytics that you you are doing or
performing they're likely coming from
some type of human scorer which is which
is really valuable but uh challenging to
scale in practice
um evolves are are a team sport kind of
what I was talking about before we want
to make sure that we're bringing a ton
of people into the fold not just
technical folks but also nontechnical
folks they can add a lot of value to uh
to your agent because of their domain
unique domain expertise and proximity to
users. They're probably not coming into
the spreadsheet is is my point. Uh and
it's slow. Um each time you eval um you
have to go through probably a little bit
of a cumbersome process to to recreate
or append to the spreadsheet.
Um, so, uh, probably the one of the, uh,
um, most fun conversations that, uh, I
have in my job is I'll have, you know, a
very proud product engineer that gets on
a call with me and, you know, they they
puff their chest out and they smirk at
me and they say, "Well, I can just vibe
code branch. It's no problem." Um, and I
think for for like like if if if you're
just getting starting your journey, it's
a really nice step to to go to. So now
instead of being in a spreadsheet land,
you're making something a little bit
more bespoke for other other people to
bring them into the fold. So now you've
probably got a for loop. You have a
nicer UI now, so it's more approachable.
And hopefully you've graduated into some
database that that isn't Excel or Google
Sheets. should probably um you know use
roll roll a new database in in something
like neon or or something. Um so now you
have a a better story around persistence
of eval. Uh and because of this you're
bringing more people into the fold. You
are making UIs that are a little bit
more bespoke for your specific users. Um
the thing that's that's a problem here
is that you're still not really
iterating yet. you're still performing
work that is a little bit more uh just
reporting just documentation rather than
encouraging a lot of a lot of iteration.
So more of a reporting tool here. How
many people have vibe coded their own uh
UI? Yeah, makes sense.
Uh next step here so you want to
encourage a lot of um experimentation
not just with technical users but with
non-technical users. So um you know I'm
showing this uh image that is more
aligned to allowing experimentation
for nontechnical users but of course as
you're building these platforms you want
to allow for more SDK driven experience
as well. Uh that just doesn't make for
for a very nice image in a in a
presentation.
So experimentation to me means that you
can give a user access to a an agent a a
configuration of an agent and a sandbox
and you allow them to tweak certain
parameters within within that agent. In
my example here, I'm allowing a user in
the UI to change the system instructions
to an agent running outside of my eval
platform and allowing them to compare
two different configurations of that of
that of that system prompt and I'm
running eval across those two different
agent runs so that I can bubble up
scores. You can you can see that in the
image now. I can bubble up different
scores to understand both technically
and functionally how my agent is
behaving. Um, so this is like you'll
hear about a lot of platforms have a
playground feature. You're going to want
some type of playground feature both for
technical and nontechnical users. This
is where the rubber starts beating the
road because the best way to perform
eval is to um really think about the
failure modes that your agent can fall
into um and build scoring functions
around those failure modes. The best way
to find those failure modes in the first
place is to have access to production
trace data i.e. your agent in front of
real users users and and real usage. So
the next step here is a really important
one. We want to make sure that we can
connect what we at least internally we
call the flywheel. Observability and
eval to us it's actually the same
problem from a from a systems
perspective. Um funny story we used to
be uh three years ago when we started we
were only an eval platform and then we
noticed one of our customers was running
this massive eval
like a every hour of every day. So we
reached out to this person and they
said, "Oh yeah, I'm just piping all of
my production traffic into this database
and I'm running an eval against it." So
we're like, "Okay, we should probably
just make make that ability to trace uh
and and observe actual traffic and be
and account for that use case without
having to cram it into offline evals. Uh
so this is really important make sure
that we can observe things in production
understand the actual behavior of our
agents also understand the the real lift
that the changes that we're making to
our agents are are having. Um so we're
analyzing that data. Uh we pull that
back those actual examples back into an
offline environment and then we improve
upon those using offline evals. This is
a loop so it's it's not just a process.
uh you're going to be performing this
loop hopefully for the lifetime of the
agent that that you're pushing to
production. You you you should be
iterating this loop as many times as
possible. That's how you that's how you
improve.
Um so as a result of that you you've
changed your scope a little. You've
widened your scope a lot actually. You
are now a tracing platform. You're now a
logging platform in addition to being an
offline eval platform. Again, the
benefit of that is that you got you're
starting to get far higher signal from
how users are interacting with uh with
your agents and you can use those real
interactions. Uh so you can um almost
think about eval
production in a safe environment. You're
now getting to uh to that point. Um with
uh with with this example, um you can
also perform online eval. So you can
point scoring functions to your uh to
your observability traffic and perform
things like alerting. Um all things that
you could build in when you're at this
phase of maturity for uh for running
emails. Uh the bad here uh if you build
it, you have to manage it. So just
because you've you know uh vibe coded a
platform, guess what? You might get a
promotion for it, but also like that's
going to be your job now. uh is is to is
to manage and and continue to grow your
eval platform at the pace that the
industry is moving. Um which can be an
exciting challenge. That's kind of the
bet that that our company's making and
we're excited to solve that problem. The
more important challenge though is that
agent traces specifically, if you kind
of look on the on the screen, these are
really nasty. They're not like normal
application traces. Um they are they are
really semistructured. A lot of times
they're unstructured. there's just a ton
of text inherent to LM problems that
we're that we're solving. Um they're um
just like very large in addition to
being complicated. So if you're trying
to cram, you know, a a one gigabyte
trace into a Postgress row, that can
lead to a lot of performance problems.
Uh and they're numerous. It's high
velocity uh because there's so much
usage happening in production hopefully
with the with the agent that you've
pushed.
Um, so this is how we used to solve this
problem. Uh, just as an example, if if
you're at this stage in maturity, you've
got traces coming in. You're going to
need to account for two query patterns.
One, if you're performing observability,
you need a way for for folks to
instantly be able to see their traces.
It's very important to people. So,
you'll need uh a a a very low latency
way to ingest data. And then uh you also
need a a second uh um a second layer of
persistence for the query pattern of I
want to be able to analyze in in
aggregate these data. So we used to use
an open- source data warehouse for this.
And we used to stitch these two sources
together uh through a a a domain
specific language that we created called
BTQL that no one liked and and including
us we we hated it. And then we would
perform like a third level of of
aggregation with using duct db in the in
the browser. Um this worked for us for
for a bit h and then it it didn't work
when um I'll just use one of our
customer examples a customer like notion
for um as an example just a ton of a lot
of of unstructured data that they were
sending us. They wanted to be able to
perform things like full text search
across a trace. None of these
technologies are really equipped to
perform text style um analytics which is
a challenge with with the LM domain
because there just so much text.
So that leads us to this um measuring
Asian quality performing eval performing
observability. It's actually a systems
problem. It's not just a UI UX problem.
We recognize that it's quite easy to
vibe code the UI of evals. Um, but it's
way way way more challenging to create
that data layer of of running a
successful eval and observability
platform. And not just from a scale
perspective, although that matters,
mostly from a functional perspective of
allowing people to do the things that
they would expect to do like performing
full text search across millions of
traces um in in their platform of
choice. Um I talked about this a little
bit. The the reason why this is such a
novel problem to solve is across a lot
of these dimensions, which I you know I
won't drain this slide, but um the data
comes in really fast. uh the data are
are are like just really large when they
come in. So even even though traditional
uh spans in a trace span is just like
one part of a trace, traditional span
would be like a couple kilobytes. Here
we've seen spans that are 10 20
megabytes in size just so much context
within those spans. Um highly highly
unstructured and then also there are a
lot of different types of read patterns.
So um you might be performing aggregate
types of read patterns but also you want
very low latency types of of read read
patterns. So none of these problems are
are individually unique but together
they make a make for a very uh unique
problem from a systems perspective.
Uh so what we've done is um and you know
what you all would have to endeavor to
do if you were building this yourselves
is you really have to think about making
the right data platform for traces so
that you can perform some of the more
functional um requirements that that
eventually come down the line. The
example that I have here is that you
know let's say that you want to let a
coding agent loose on your evals
platform so that you can be a little bit
more self-healing with grabbing data in
aggregate from your evals platform using
a coding agent to grab that into context
and change your agent uh within um you
know with with within a a coding agent
session. That's something that's going
to be really challenging to do if you
can't run a lot of just pure SQL on the
data back end of of your evals platform.
We've actually noticed a lot of these
headless style use cases come up where
people aren't in interested in the UI at
all. The only thing that they're
interested in is how can I perform eval
in a way where I can use a codeex or I
can use a cloud code to to help uh um
help increase the quality of my agent
for me. So the the last problem here
that that I'll talk about is the so what
problem. Um and we'll we'll skip this
for now for the sake of time. This is
how Brain Trust does this. We have a
blog about this if if you're interested
that that just got released. Um
um but what what kind of comes next here
for um what you can expect to build into
your evals platform is you want to be
able to tell folks the unknown unknowns
of your agent. I.e. don't make me look
across a whole bunch of traces. Just
tell me how people are are using uh our
our agent. Uh so you want to be able to
uncover those unknown unknowns unknown
unknowns through topic modeling
techniques so that you know where to
spend your engineering time. Um you want
to make sure that you are building your
platform not just for humans but also
for agents because that's one of the
main media for how people are are
creating technology. Now um we didn't
even talk about the non-functional
requirements that go into building these
platforms like role-based access control
data masking. That's also something that
that's super important that comes up
when you want to operate at scale. Uh
and then lastly, uh a consideration for
adding
automatic tracing through some type of
AI proxy or or gateway so that people
don't even have a choice but to trace
their their LMS. Um you can govern very
centrally by adding tracing
automatically uh to uh to your eval
platform.
Um so I appreciate the time. I'm I've
got like a minute and 20 seconds left
for for questions. I can probably take
two of them if anyone has any questions.
Yes.
>> Okay. Um I'm not sure about
these kind of
problems often you create like dynamic
promps
only
like solutions.
Then you often build like custom
version. How does brain trust?
>> So like how does brain brain trust
specifically handle multimodal outputs
and inputs and traces?
>> Yeah, we like just very technically we
uh put them in some object storage,
reference them and then um display them
directly into the trace. So if you have
like an audio file or a video file, you
can play it in the trace when someone's
reviewing the the trace itself. We don't
want people to have to exit the platform
for that.
>> The prompt management is in brain trust.
>> It could be. Yeah. A question was is
prompt management in brain trust? It it
it could be or it doesn't have to be.
Yeah.
Okay. Perfect. Thank you so much for
your attention today.